>> Chris: THANK YOU.
AND AGAIN, JOINING US FOR
"SPECIAL REPORT" TOMORROW FOR
BRET BAIER'S INTERVIEW WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS NEGOTIATIONS
WITH NORTH KOREA MIGHT NOT HAVE
BEEN POSSIBLE WITHOUT THE TRAGIC
DEATH OF AMERICAN STUDENT OTTO
WARMBIER WHO DIED AFTER BEING
RELEASED FROM A NORTH KOREAN
PRISON ONE YEAR AGO.
TODAY HIS PARENTS TWEETED THIS.
WE APPRECIATE PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
RECENT COMMENTS ABOUT OUR
FAMILY.
WE ARE PROUD OF OTTO WARMBIER
AND MISSING.
HOPEFULLY SOMETHING POSITIVE CAN
COME FROM THIS.
NOW TO WORLD REACTION.
NO OTHER COUNTRY HAS MORE AT
STAKE TONIGHT FROM THIS SUMMIT
IN SOUTH KOREA.
THAT'S WHERE SENIOR FOREIGN
AFFAIRS CORRESPONDENT CAKE,
GREG PALKOT IS RIGHT NOW.
>> THE INK WASN'T EVEN DRY ON
THE DECLARATION PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND NORTH KOREAN LEADER KIM JONG
AND SIGNED AT THEIR HISTORIC
SUMMIT IN SINGAPORE PROMISING
COMPLETE DENUCLEARIZATION OF THE
KOREAN PENINSULA BEFORE THE
GLOBAL NAYSAYERS ZEROED IN.
IRAN, WHICH RECENTLY SAW THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION BACK OUT OF
ITS NUCLEAR DEAL, HAD A WARNING
FOR PYONGYANG.
>> THE U.S. ADMINISTRATION'S
FAILURE TO HONOR ITS COMMITMENTS
MAKES US WATCH MR. TRUMPS
BEHAVIOR WITH PESSIMISM AND I
THINK THE NORTH KOREAN
GOVERNMENT SHOULD HANDLE THIS
WITH FULL VIGILANCE.
>> CHINA SHOWING SIGNS OF
BACKING OUT OF INTERNATIONAL
SANCTIONS AGAINST THE NORTH
THINKS THEIR GRIP SHOULD BE
EASED.
>> THE U.N. RESOLUTIONS SAY THAT
ACT IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE
RESOLUTION AND SANCTION MEASURES
COULD BE ADJUSTED WHICH COULD
INCLUDE PAUSING OR MOVING IN.
>> IN SOUTH KOREA, THE COUNTRY
WITH THE MOST AT STAKE,
PRESIDENT MOON JAE-IN ADMITTED
HE HAD BEEN NERVOUS BEFORE THE
SUMMIT AND WISH FOR THE BEST.
>> I SPENT A SLEEPLESS NIGHT.
I SINCERELY HOPE THAT IT WILL
OPEN A NEW ERA OF
DENUCLEARIZATION, PEACE, A NEW
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE TWO
KOREAS AND THE UNITED STATES.
>> THEY MIGHT BE LOSING MORE
SLEEP AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
SUSPENSION OF THE U.S. AND
SOUTH KOREAN JOINT MILITARY
EXERCISES.
THEY HAD TO FIGURE OUT THE EXACT
MEANING OF THE TRUMP PLEDGE.
EXPERTS WHO SEE THE TROLLS AS A
DEFENSIVE BULWARK AGAINST
NORTH KOREA ARE EDGY.
>> SOUTH KOREAN --
>> PRACTICAL.
>> STILL, LOCALS WHO HAVE HAD
THE PIECE HOPES RAISED BEFORE,
WATCHED THE SUMMIT CLOSELY.
THEY, WILL THE DAILY UNDER THE
THREAT OF WAR, SEEMED HAPPY TO
SEE PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
NORTH KOREAN LEADER KIM
EXCHANGING PLEASANTRIES, NOT
BARBS.
>> BETTER THAN PAPER TO PAPER.
>> FACE TO FACE.
>> I WANT TO KEEP THE REPUBLIC
OF KOREA.
>> IT'S WEDNESDAY MORNING HERE
IN SEOUL.
SECRETARY OF STATE POMPEO
ARRIVES HERE LATER TODAY TO
EXPLAIN THE RESULTS OF THE
SUMMIT, ESPECIALLY PERHAPS THE
DECISION PRESIDENT TRUMP TO
SUSPEND THOSE MILITARY EXERCISES
HERE IN SOUTH KOREA AND THEN TO
PLOT THE WAY FORWARD, INCLUDING